Big...
mood.
What does it mean?
I may be out of the loop and registered completely uncool by pretty much everyone on the internet...(So True)
But I'd like to think that I keep up pretty well with the linguistics of today's youth.
Everyone has started to scream at the top of their lungs at random cliff heights:
B I G  M O O D
Or if I post a picture that has a certain sour expression...
BiG mOoD
If I'm talking about something that somebody can relate to...
"Big mood!"
Detective Markiplier (not really a detective tho) is on the job here to discover exactly what "big mood" means.
Its origin, and what it could mean for you and your family.
Is "big mood" coming to kill you...
...where you sleep tonight?
That's what we're gonna find out. "These are a lot of very important questions to answer, Markiplier!"
"Why thank you very much! I'd like to think I'm a contributing member of society!"
"That--uh-- oh no, that's wrong. :/"
Bigg Mood. Bigg, double G, big, big mood. Big mnOOD- What does "big mnood" get me to? Big mnood?
Aww, no, I want big mnood.
What?
Video: Slow, distorted audio
*Mark laughing*
Ah.
All righty, then. I don't think that's right. That's...
I think something's VERY wrong with that. I don't think that's anybody's big mood, but big mood.
What is big mood?
What is this?
"You stay positive. You always believe that everything is going to work out! How do you do it?"
"Well, I'll tell you my secret sir."
"I lie to myself. I say everything's gonna be ok,"
"BUT I'M LYING."
And I don't know how much longer I can do it."
BIG MOOD
All right then, thank you, Skittlez Ju- *starts laughing*
Skittlez Juice for that one, but not what I'm looking for.
Big Mood, Urban Dictionary, the one source of information I can trust in this world.
*voicecrack" See!
Wow, excuse me. Just went through puberty a li'l bit more.
See, it's relatively new, and not a lot of people know about it.
But people keep talking about it!
*reads* "Relatable, said in response to something that you agree with."
It sounds like something that a caveman would say in response to something like his fresh kill.
"Unga-bunga brought home the biggest--" I hate this joke I'm going for--"Unga Bunga brought home the biggest
saber-tooth tiger today."
"noise*
"Big mood."
That doesn't help me. Here we go, even a Reddit post doesn't know what big mood means.
There's only one response!
Let's see. *reads* "I'll break it down this way. Big is for the amount of mood, obviously,
while mood refers to the way you feel, right?
So this hypothetical detective is the link--
is saying 'dead body in the corner?'
'That's how I'm feeling very much'. In short, Big Mood = I feel pretty dead too, Mr. Corpse."
Wait... *reads* "me as a detective walking up look at a dead body: ok first of all, big mood,"
That's got a hundred and fifty thousand notes?!
How?!
*Gibberish*
I-I think I gotta go to the root form of mood.
Uh, mood?
*slow distorted music*
Is this one of Ethan's first videos?
Oh, we're still not closer to the truth! Just shut up, shut up for one goddamn second! Stop mooding me up.
No answers for me, no answers to anything, I don't understand... I don't know what's going on.
I think I gotta ask you guys. You guys have never let me down before.
"n e v e r   l e t   m e   d o w n   b e f o r e "
You guys, whenever I ask you something, you take it honestly...
"h o n e s t l y"
You answer me correctly...
"c o r r e c t l y"
Quickly...
*unintelligible*
And I appreciate every single time you do because it always fills me in so
Appropriately, and then I'm not left out of the loop. I'm just gonna ask.
"What does big mood mean?"
Just a simple question, right? What does big mood mean?
1-800-are-you-slappin. You...are not helping.
No.
A mood that's-- thank you. No duh, Lauren. NO DUH, LAUREN. N O  D U H
"it's like saying I feel you." I don't wanna feel anybody.
"lmao mood." What?? You can't define a--a word with the word.
"how u feel but big." Alright, that's pretty close to it. I think you're getting closer there.
Big mood. big mood. big mood. big D. mood. mood. big mood. big mood.
Like you feel something like hard in the feels ya feel
No
No, I don't feel. You not knowing what it means...
That's a big mood. Your mood, but it's big. Something you relate to so much
It's your mood. The opposite of a small mood. Is depression an acceptable answer? Yes.
This.
*confused Mark stuttering*
NO
Why is this so jpeg? How many times has this been screenshat???
Okay, I got that saved I just need it. That's why I needed to do that for a second save that for later
Don't worry about it lol. opposite of small mood. I refuse to explain a meme to you.
Do you really want to know it really means some of you relate to you tell you to I don't want to tell you?
I can't tell you if I don't know!
when your emotional state is significantly enlarged by a given amount dependent on the magnitude of your situation it means that the
matriarchal figure that lives in the center of the earth is sending out wavelengths so bit that we're both so
That we're all feeling the same emotions is called a big mood because a larger big portion of the population
Is it feeling it the mood together huge relateable you mean this?
That's not what it means. Big mood, no, that's my big butt. Something you'll understand when you get tall.
eh fuck you!
I'm not getting to the meat of the matter. I don't think big mood can be translated through text
Please send me a video of yourself
Explaining what big mood means, or is or does in five seconds or less?
I got I don't have a lot of time for this so. I need your help
very serious
That's a little desperate. There we go. People will get that people will understand that it's gonna take people a while
So I'm gonna kill some time
Alright there should be answers by now.
"Uh it's like when you SUBSCRIBE TO CRANKGAMEPLAYS DO IT RIGHT NOW WHILE YOU HAVE THE CHANCE" *mark screaming*
Big mood is your mood. But bigger. Easy.
*mark stuttering* wha- that doesn't make any...
*slow mechanical noises*
*windows error sound* no!
Why does everyone talk about big moods? why not small moods? like why not medium moods?
Cuz no one gives a shit, that's why!
big mood.
No.
well........fuck you!
...............no.
oh--OOHHHHH I'M REAL CLEVER AND ORIGINAL OHHH MY NAME SMHCRANK
*somewhat chewbacca-ish noise*
A big fucking mood is when you get eleven chicken nuggets in a ten piece order
OHHHHHH NOW I GET IT
That was a perfect explanation
Big mood is a big mood the definition is in the words
That's not how a definition works you lazy piece of crap.
It's when you relate to something extremely
Thank you. Thank you
Hmmmm it means when you're relating to something
*high pitched* mmmmmmMMMMM IIIIIIIIIIII
Don't know about that one. Uh oh
Big mood is the spirit it's a feeling state of mind
That's perfect. Thank you.
WHOOOOAAAAA I GET IT
"big mood is what you say when you see something that's relatable and it's like "Oh! i want tacos!" and this person replies with "oh. big mood!" you know. Same."
Ahhh. When you describe it in food look of course I get it. "Big mood is a cooler way of saying hashtag relatable"
Is it cooler is it cooler? Is it cooler is it? IS IT REALLYYYYYYYY????
nnnnnnno!
Oh. Oh. Oh. OOOO a picture diagram!
Wait a minute. Wait no! No! Did you tell me this already?
Big mood means you need to sit down, mister, and go to bed.
*I think he's trying to be mocking but he kinda looks crazy*
big mood means you sound like this BIG MOOD MEANS YOU SAOUND LAIK DIS HYUH OH AUH
Okay, you know I've seen enough. Okay. All right. I think I properly understand what big mood means.
Big mood...
*litty music*
So I don't know if you guys agree with that let me don't actually don't let me know down in the comments below
Let me know down the mood section down below
Let me know if this video is deserving of a great big mood. And don't-- don't ring the bell for more videos.
Blast bigly the bugle horn of
mood
And thanks again for watching
and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh-bye!!!
*outro music: Crazy La Paint*